luke bryan we just heard you rehearsing
out there how did it feel well how was
it it sounded great
you could give me a bad yelp review if
you'd like no no how did it feel no it
feels good i mean um just happy to be
doing this with jordan such a great big
song for him getting you know so many
nominations so i'm honored to be in the
room it must feel good too to be back in
vegas especially because last year at
the acms you had to miss it
unfortunately so how good does it feel i
know i mean
to win entertainment of the year last
year and i kind of had to be on the set
at american idol
um kind of got a lot of things going on
with american idol but it was really an
honor to win
and and to be the entertainer of the
year and i'm certainly excited to see
um who who gets it this year and um
but yeah it's going to be a fun night
and any time in vegas i've always
thought the vegas element adds a big
party for the acms now those are all
your friends in the entertainment right
right category you can't choose one can
you no you don't you don't really get
into that world you just um i mean my
thing is
always i've got people
um
that you always feel like they're
deserving and before their career is up
you always
pray they get one you know it's a once i
won my first you know my first
entertainer of the year was at acms and
it's just such a validating
um
it's a validating moment in your career
and
and i'm so so thankful to have have won
it and look at you now just wrapped up
the first part of your vegas residency
how did that all go it was great i mean
i couldn't be happier with the show i
really feel like it's one of the best
shows i've ever been able to put on and
perform
and i also learned that that i can live
one month in vegas without uh
yeah without getting sent to the grave
[Laughter]
how much trouble did your mom get into
my mother is
she's in trouble with me because i you
know she's really crafty at borrowing
money from multiple people so yeah now
i'm going around hearing all the debts
she accrued well listen you're going to
make more money here though because you
have more vegas residency shows no it's
not that it's not the point you don't
take the money that you make in vegas
and give it back on the tables that's
kind of counterproductive are you
already thinking about round two for
your vegas residency or are you kind of
like i need a breather for a second and
then you'll wrap your mind around it
well i mean with me i mean this year i
kind of chalked this year up to be one
of the busier years of my life and the
main thing is just
rest when i can rest and uh
but as far as round two i mean i always
want to build on the vegas show even if
we have repeat people that come out
multiple times i always want them to be
able to see
different things but but
the vegas show will morph and become
even something i'm more comfortable with
and then that you know this year we've
got the raised up right tour that's uh
that i've got a whole nother tour going
on so
so yeah i'm going we were talking off
camera i'm gonna need one margarita two
margaritas and some spicy margaritas and
some watermelon margaritas and yeah all
versions all of that at the end of this
year now you mentioned repeat people
come to the shows
has your american idol family been able
to check out the residency they haven't
but i was able to catch katie's show
friday night because of acms and i came
in a day early just to be able to
because it's going to be really tough
for our for our schedules to intersect
to where we can come so
so um i mainly did that just to put a
lot of pressure on katie so she would
have to come see my show would you think
of hers oh i loved it i mean it's such a
different
um
well the beauty of all the shows that
are at resorts world are they're all
different in their own
in their own reasons and you know i've
never been to a lot of pop concerts but
i mean katie's show is just a visual
i mean and even i've seen her show on
her last tour
but i just love what she's able to put
together in the theater it's really
creative really visual
and
you know i i'm just
a huge fan of what katie does always
have been and now to know her as a
friend and to be a you know to be on
idol with her it's just uh it's like
literally sitting there cheering my
sister on hoping she's having fun so you
know obvi there's two fellow idol family
members also hosting the show now this
year
gabby and jimmy giving him any advice oh
well i just saw gabby and just you know
kind of hugged her and said
you know good luck and and uh
it's a fun thing to see the next
generation come along i mean certainly
had a lot of memories hosting the acms
and a lot of anxieties and worries and
fears and to see a newer crop coming
along knowing that they're going to be
excited hosting it's it's fun all the
way around last question for you i like
this fashion moment here we've got a
little dolce gabbana going oh how'd you
uh oh you saw that i did not know
buttons too oh yeah see i didn't know
that's what it said i thought you know
anyway but will you have will you have
multiple uh outfit changes because you
have two performances well you know
we're doing our performance together
okay so um i would have to get naked in
front of everybody and trust me
we don't want that
so you're staying in one house
you